toutes les villes n'ont pas la chance
d'avoir leur comédie française mais
grâce à une idée ingénieuse
elles sont une centaine à avoir invité
leurs habitants à assister à une
représentation exceptionnelle des
fourberies de scapin pareil comédiens du
français en personne pierre-emmanuel
duclair en seine-maritime cent clochers
sagres en place et sa comédie française
aujourd'hui on y donne les fourberies de
scapin et s'il vous plaît dans l'une de
ses plus belles mises en scène celle de
jean louis benoit avec philippe torreton
dans le rôle titre
évidemment des comédies françaises il
n'y en a qu'une en fait la pièce a été
enregistré avant d'être projetée sur
grand écran en haute définition
non il n'ya pas la comédie française où
on reçoit la comédie-française en direct
via satellite par la parabole qui est
ici donc l'image est directement émises
par satellite de paris
cette première devrait être renouvelée
deux à trois fois par an grâce à ce
réseau une centaine de petites communes
comme duclair a pu se croire le temps
d'une pièce dans le plus prestigieux
théâtres de france
le travail des acteurs et du metteur en
scène perd beaucoup bien sûr à sa autre
inscription sur un écran et le public
des connaisseurs lui ne s'y trompe pas
et comme et des îles sont prêtes où ils
attendent et puis tu as une personne qui
tape avec un bâton 1 2 3 le rideau se
lève et là il commence à jouer c'était
pareil ouais la peau tendue à 2,3 sur
l'écran c'est vrai ils auront vu la
pièce jouée par des acteurs
d'aujourd'hui dans une mise en scène
d'aujourd'hui
donc ils auront vu une véritable
interprétation au sens noble et grands
du terme d'une pièce de théâtre
classique rideau est tombé l'écran vidéo
cet état chacun restera peut-être un peu
sur sa faim au moins jusqu'à la
prochaine représentation
tous